do you think for teaching and in general
but thinking about new concepts do you
think it's better to plug in the numbers
or to think more abstractly so looking
at theorems and proving the theorems or
actually you know building up a
basically tuition of the theorem or the
method the approach and then just
plugging in numbers and seeing it work
you know well certainly many of us like
to see examples first we understand it
might be a pretty heavy strike sounding
example like a three dimensional
rotation how are you gonna how are you
going to understand a rotation in 3d or
in ten D or but and then some of us like
to keep going with it to the point where
you got numbers where you got ten angles
ten axes ten angles but the best the
great mathematicians probably I don't
know if they do that because they they
for them for them an example would be a
highly abstract thing to the rest of it
right but nevertheless working within
the space of examples yeah example it
seems to the examples of structure our
brain seem to connect with that yeah
you